you know Johan is not a racist
I really want that here
yes but people who no but what is 1 racist
I always think that is such a thing I think
yes you can make racist statements
but you are not a racist
yes but yes it is
no one likes to be called out for
racist
but at 1 time when it sounds like 1 racist
isn't it just 1 racist
Uhm but maybe you
you can also make 1 mistake and then you can say
yes this is this
this is 1 they have been driven out more often
so yes then you should also address him
if you are going to shout
yes you should not join her anymore
I think of the level
we are going to call advertisers
that they no longer
to learn from that program
I think that I think that is 1 step too far
the fact that
talk to All about this now that you are here now
but where is the limit
yes that is 1 good question
I think we should determine it over and over again
yes I am afraid we will move it up
which is of course also important
often that is the one who is talking about
also indicates the limit 1 bit
yes in this case
sorry Are you too
well you did
you said what you wanted to say
there are indeed just opmerkingenjuistheid of them
people who said you shouldn't write there anymore
do you think you are no longer there
should write as a political
Uhm that's everyone's own consideration
and a lot of people watch it
I have also looked at it quite often
I especially like when it comes to football
I must honestly say
I don't like the rest
exciting and fun or exciting
but less fun
it's just 1 consideration from everyone
so I wouldn't see 1 general no
the route of such an exchange runs
namely always 1 bit the same
it starts with 1 with 1
well let's say border
distinctive comment
or 1 racist comment or whatever
then lifts so much
after that someone says you shouldn't write it down
after that someone says
you don't like her
uh no uh you shouldn't accept her around it
Tim Hofman has already done that with angry van
you shouldn't accept her anymore
and then uh how sick is that
that's sick
they say they are canceled and
and tomorrow it will be over
yes I would like to end with 1 Small fragment
I have seen it 3 times
and I found the same fragment all 3 times
very nice the beginning
of your made in speech
the first speech
that you do when you are in the second room
as the youngest chamber lit ever
in which you put yourself down very briefly
ok when i was 4 weeks old
I was fondled by my biological mother
in 1 cafe in Arezabba
2 police officers
took me to the nearest orphanage
in that city
1 few months later I was adopted
because of my dirty hoitemem
who put me in this world
that is unknown to me
but who have given me the loving education
so that I can stand in this place today
there is no doubt about that
and I'm going to tell you
we are going to hear a lot from this boy
so absolutely I can say one more thing about it
yes because Uhm it seems like I do very often
being discriminated against
I grew up in freezer then
in 1 environment where people have always loved me
I had the best football coach in Het Dorp
the sweetest parents
the best teachers
they have given me opportunities
and the fact that I am in the
politics is pure reasoning
because I want to give something back
and eh
regardless of what Joan derks or whatever idiot says it
I'm going to do that
the quality thank you